let me ask you about
the uh situation in Israel uh why did
Hamas attack Israel on October 7th 2023
as you understand the
situation what was the reason that
attack
happened well I think the main reason
was that you had this suffocating
occupation I think if as long as the
occupation
persists the Palestinians are going to
resist uh as you well know this is not
the first time there has been a
Palestinian Uprising there was the first
inata there was the second in tata now
there's October 7th and there are
uprisings besides those three uh so this
is not terribly
surprising uh a lot of people hypothesis
ized that uh this attack was due to the
fact that uh the Israelis the Saudis and
the Americans were working together to
Foster another Abraham Accord uh and
that the Palestinians would in effect be
sold down the river uh I think given the
fact that this was in the planning
stages for probably about two years uh
and the Abraham Accords with regard to
Saudi Arabia or relatively new
phenomenon I don't think that's uh the
main driving force here I think the main
driving force is that the
Palestinians uh feel oppressed as they
should and that this was uh a resistance
move they were resisting the Israeli
occupation so that
resistance the attack involved killing a
large number of Israeli civilians
there's many questions asked there but
one is do you think Hamas fully
understood what the retaliation will
involve from Israel into
Gaza they had to understand I
mean you had you know operation castled
in
200 uh 8 2009 it started I think right
after Christmas 2008 and it ended right
before President Obama took office uh in
January 2009 and uh uh the Israelis
periodically do what they call mowing
the lawn where they go into Gaza and
they pound the
Palestinians uh to remind them that
they're not supposed to rise up and
cause any problem uh
so there's no question in my mind that
the uh the Hamas forces understood full
well that the Israelis would retaliate
and they would retaliate in force as
they have done yeah even the metaphor of
Mo the lawn is disturbing to me in many
ways actually
saw uh Norman filin I think say that
well then if you use that metaphor then
you could say that Hamas was also mowing
the lawn that's such a horrific
image because the result on either side
is just the death of
civilians I mean let me ask you about
the death of civilians so during the
attack 1400 Israelis were
killed over 240 were taken hostage and
then in response as we sit
today uh Israel's military response has
killed over 10,000 people in Gaza and
given the nature of the demographics
it's it's a very heavy young population
over 40% of them are under the age of 18
of those killed that's uh of course
according to Ministry of Health of
Palestinian
Authority so what do you think is the
long-term effect on the prospect of
Peace when so many civilians
die I mean I think it's disastrous
U uh I
mean the only way you're going to get
piece here uh is if you have a two-state
solution um where the Palestinians have
a sovereign state of their own and there
is a sovereign Jewish State uh and these
two states live side by side American
Presidents since Jimmy Carter have
understood this full well and this is
why we have pushed very hard for
two-state solution indeed many American
Jews and many Israelis have pushed for a
two-state solution because they think
think that that is the only way you're
going to get uh peace uh between the two
sides uh but what's happened here is
that in recent years the Israelis have
lost all interest in a two-state
solution uh and it's in large part
because the political center of gravity
in Israel has steadily moved to the
right uh when I was a young boy uh the
political center of gravity in Israel
was much further to the left than it is
today and uh it is in uh it is in a
position now the political center of
gravity where there's hardly any support
for two-state solution and Netanyahu and
the rest of the people in his government
were in favor or are in favor of a
greater Israel there's just no question
about
that
well on top of that you now have had a
war where as you
described huge numbers of civilians have
been killed and you already had bad
blood between the Palestinians and the
Israelis before this
conflict uh and you could imagine how
people on each side now feel about
people on the other side so even if you
didn't have this opposition inside
Israel to a two-state
solution how could you possibly get the
Israelis now to agree to a two-state
solution I think for the foreseeable
future the animosity inside Israel
towards the Palestinians is so great
that it is impossible to move the
Israelis in that direction and the
Israelis here are the key players more
so than the Palestinians because it's
the Israelis who control greater Israel
it's the Israelis who you have to
convince now I want to be clear here you
also ultimately have to get around the
fact that Hamas right is not committed
to a two-state solution but I think that
problem could be dealt with it's
important to understand that Arafat and
the PLO was once adamantly opposed to a
two-state solution but Arafat came
around to understand that that was
really the only hope for settling this
and he became a proponent of a two-state
solution and that's true of mmud abas
who runs the PA in the West
bank it's not true of hos at this point
in time they want a one-state solution
they want a Palestinian State and of
course the Israelis want a one-state
solution too which is a Jewish state
that controls all of U all of Greater
Israel so the question is can you get
some sort of agreement and I think to
get to your the Nu of your question
given what's just happened uh it's
almost impossible to imagine that
happening anytime time soon the cynical
perspective here is that uh those in
power benefit from conflict while the
people on both sides suffer is there a
degree of Truth to that or for the
people in power to maintain power
conflict needs to continue no I I don't
believe that I mean just to take the
Netanyahu government or any Israeli
government that maintains uh the
occupation what you want is you want uh
a Palestinian population that submits to
Israeli domination of Greater Israel you
don't want resistance you don't want an
inapa you don't want what happened on
October 7th in fact I think one of the
principal reasons that the Israelis are
pounding Gaza and killing huge numbers
of civilians punishing the civilian
population in ways that clearly violate
the laws of war is because they want the
Palestinians to understand that they are
not allowed to rise up and resist the
occupation that's their goal so I think
the Israelis would prefer that the
Palestinians roll over and accept
submission in terms of the people who
live in Gaza to include the elites and
the people who live in the West Bank to
include the elites they would much
prefer to move to some sort of situation
where uh the Palestinian have a state of
their own I think in the case of the pa
uh under abas they would accept a
two-state solution I think what at this
point in time Hamas wants is a one-state
solution but they want peace all of them
want peace uh you know the two different
sets of leadership in Palestine and the
Israelis so you think Hamas wants peace
sure but on its own terms that's the
point what does peace look like for
Hamas at this point in time I think
peace basically means a greater Israel
controlled by Palestine or
Palestinians okay so essentially I mean
it's the whole land is called Palestine
and there's no Israel I think at this
point in time that's their principal
goal I do believe and there have been
hints over time Jimmy Carter has said
this that Hamas can be convinced that a
two-state solution assuming that the
Palestinians get a viable uh state of
their own that Hamas would buy into that
can we say that with a high degree of
certainty no but I think I think the
Israelis should have pursued that
possibility they should have worked with
theas they should have worked with Hamas
to do everything they can to facilitate
a two-state solution because I think
ultimately that's in Israel's interest
now the Israeli government and most
Israelis at this point in time I believe
don't agree with that what do you think
of Israel starting the ground invasion
of Gaza recently on October 27th the
question
is uh should they
continue uh until they have finally
defeated
Hamas uh there are all sorts of reports
in the media including in the Israeli
media that they're not going to be
allowed by the United States to continue
this
offensive uh from much more than a few
weeks um the Israelis have been saying
it would it's going to take in in the
best of all possible worlds a number of
months if not a year to finish off Hamas
well it doesn't look like they're going
to have enough time to do that I doubt
whether they can finish off Hamas even
if they're given the time uh I think
they're going to run into Fierce
resistance uh and when they run into
fierce resistance and large numbers of
Israelis going to die start to die uh
they'll lose their appetite for this and
they the Israelis surely know at this
point in time that even if they finish
off Hamas even if I'm wrong and they're
able to finish off Hamas another group
is going to rise up to uh resist the
occupation the idea that you can use
what Z Yaba insky called The Iron Wall
to beat the pal Palestinians into
submission is delusional it's just not
going to happen the Palestinians want a
state of their own they don't want to
live under
occupation and uh there's no military
solution for Israel here there has to be
a political solution and the only viable
political solution is a two-state
solution I mean you can't go to
democracy you can't go to a situation
where you give the Palestinians equal
rights in inside a greater Israel in
large part because there are
now as many Palestinians as there are
Israeli Jews and over time the balance
the demographic balance shifts against
the Israeli Jews and in favor of the
Palestinians in which case you'll end up
with a Palestinian state in Greater
Israel so you know democracy for all
doesn't work uh the Israelis I believe
are quite interested in ethnical
cleansing I think they saw this um uh
this recent set of events as an
opportunity to cleanse Gaza but that's
not going to happen uh the jordanians
and the Egyptians have made it clear
that that's not happening the United
States has now made it clear that that's
not happening and and the Palestinians
will not leave uh they'll die in place
uh so uh ethnic cleansing doesn't work
so you're really left with two
alternatives a two-state solution or a
greater Israel that is effectively an
apartheid state I mean that's what the
occupation has led to and all sorts of
people have been predicting this for a
long long time and you've now reached
the point you know here in the United
States if you say that Israel is an
apartheid state that's going to get you
into all sorts of trouble but the fact
is that Human Rights Watch Amnesty
International and Bellum which is the
leading isra Human Rights group all
three of those institutions or
organizations have issued detailed
reports making the case that Israel is
an apartheid state furthermore if you
read the Israeli media right all sorts
of Israelis including Israeli
leaders refer to Israel as an apartheid
state it's it's not that unusual to hear
that term used in Israel this is
disastrous for Israel in my opinion and
Steve Walt and I said this by the way
when we wrote the Israel Lobby that
Israel is an aparte state which is
equivalent to Israel as an occupier uh
is not good for Israel uh and that
brings us back to the two-state solution
but as you and I were talking about a
few minutes ago it's hard to see how you
get a two-state
solution and the end result of this
conversation is utter
despair because the path to a two-state
solution
is blocked by the amount of um hate
that's created by civilian deaths so
that plus the fact that the Israeli
government uh is filled with people uh
who have no interest in a two-state
solution they're
ideologically deeply committed to a
greater Israel they want all the land
between the Jordan River in the
Mediterranean Sea to
be part of a Jewish state they're just
ideologically committed to that and uh
and of course as we were talking about
before with regard to Hamas Hamas wants
everything between the river and the sea
to be a Palestinian State and you know
when you have two sides with those kinds
of views right um um you're in deep
trouble because there's little room for
compromise so what you have to do to get
this to work is you have to convince the
Israelis that it's in their interest to
have a two-state solution and you have
you've already taken care of the PA on
this front the Palestinian Authority but
you've got to convince Hamas that it's
uh its maximalist goals are are not
going to work and it's in its interest
uh to follow in the footsteps of Arafat
and accept a two-state solution but uh
even if you do that at this point let's
say that you know there's a lot of
willingness uh intellectually on both
sides to do that the problem is that the
hatred that has been fueled by this
recent C uh this ongoing conflict is so
great that it's just hard to imagine how
you can make a two-state solution work
at this juncture uh that's why I've sort
of taken to saying and I hope I'm wrong
here that you know on the two-state
solution uh that that boat has sailed
it's just you know it's no longer
possible well again I believe in
leadership and there's other parties
that play here Other Nations Jordan
Saudi Arabia other other players in the
in the Middle East that can help they
can help through a normalization of
relationships and these kinds of things
there's there's always hope like you
said Slither of Hope Slither I think
human civilization progresses forward by
taking advantage of the all the slithers
it can get uh let me ask you about you
mentioned the Israel Lobby you wrote a
book probably your most controversial
book on the topic not probably clearly
the most controversial book I ever wrote
so you've uh criticized the Israel Lobby
in the United States for influencing US
policy um in the Middle East can you
explain what the Israel Lobby is their
influence and your
criticism over the past let's say a
couple
decades well the argument that Steve
Walt and I made actually we wrote an
article first and uh which appeared in
the London review of books uh and then
we wrote the book
itself uh our argument is that the lobby
is a loose Coalition of uh individuals
and
organizations uh that push American
policy in a pro-israel
direction uh and uh basically the lobby
is interested in getting Israel excuse
me getting the United States and here
we're talking me about the American
government to support Israel no matter
what Israel does and our argument is
that if you look at the relationship
between the United States and Israel
it's unprecedented in modern history uh
this is the closest relationship that
you can find between any two countries
in recorded history it's truly amazing
the extent to which Israel and the
United States are joined at the hip and
we support Israel no matter what almost
all the time uh and uh our argument is
that that is largely due to the
influence of the lobby the lobby is uh
an extremely powerful interest group now
it's very important to understand that
the American political system is set up
in ways that allow interest groups of
All Sorts to wield great influence so in
the United States you have an interest
group or a Lobby like the National Rifle
Association that makes it Welly
impossible to get gun control right uh
and so with the Israel Lobby you have
this group of individuals and
organizations that wield enormous
influence on US policy toward the Middle
East
and this
is not surprising given the nature of
the American political system uh so our
argument is that the lobby is not doing
anything that's illegal or illicit or
immoral or unethical it's just a good
old-fashioned American interest group
and it just happens to be extremely
powerful and our argument is
that this is not good for the United
States because no two countries have the
same interests all the time and when our
interests conflict with Israel's
interests we should be able to do what
we think is in our national interest in
America's national interest but the
lobby tends to conflate America's
national interests with Israel's
national interests and wants the United
States to support Israel no matter what
we also argue and I can emphasize this
enough given what's going on in the
world today that the
lobbies effects the lobby has not
been pushing policies that are in
Israel's interest so our argument is
that the lobby right the lobby pushes
policies that are not in America's
interest or not in Israel's interest now
you're saying to yourself what exactly
does he mean by
that what every president since Jimmy
car has tried to do as I said before is
to foster a two-state solution to push
Israel which is the dominant
player in Greater Israel push Israel to
accept the two-state solution and we
have run into huge resistance from the
lobby whenever we tried to let's be blun
about it co Israel right in a perfect
world where there was no Lobby and
American president was free to put
pressure on Israel to coerce Israel I
believe we would have gone a long way
towards getting two-state solution and I
believe this would have been in Israel's
interest uh but we couldn't get a
two-state solution because it was almost
impossible to put meaningful pressure on
Israel because of the lobby so this was
not an Israel's interest and it was not
in America's interest and that was the
argument that we made and we of course
got huge push back for making that
argument what's the underlying
motivation of the lobby is it religious
in nature is it um similar to the way
warhawks are sort of militaristic in
nature is it nationalistic in nature
what what's uh if you were to describe
this loose Coalition of people what what
would you say is their motivation well
first of all I think you have to
distinguish between Jews and Christians
you want to remember that there are a
huge number of Christians zionists who
are deeply committed to Israel no matter
what right and then there are a large
number of Jews the Jews are obviously
the most important of those two groups
in the Israel lobby but you know one of
the arguments that we made in the book
is that you should not call it the
Jewish Lobby because it's not populated
just by Jews and Christians zon this are
an important part of that lobby but
furthermore there are a good good number
of Jews who are opposed to the lobby uh
and the policies that the lobby purveys
and they uh a number of Jews who are
prominent
anti-zionists right so and they're
obviously not in the lobby or or if you
take a group like Jewish voice for peace
right Jewish voice for peace is not in
the lobby so it's wrong to call it a
Jewish lobby but with regard to the
American Jews who were in that Lobby uh
I I think that really this is all about
nationalism it's not so much religion
many of those Jews who are influential
in the lobby are not religious in any
meaningful sense of that term but they
self-identify as Jewish in in in the
sense that they feel they're part of a
Jewish nation and that that in addition
to being an American right they are part
of this tribe this nation called Jews
and that they have a
responsibility um to push the United
States in ways that support uh the
Jewish state so I I think that's what
drives most if not almost all the Jews
this is not to say there's not a
religious dimension for some of them but
I think that the the main connection is
much more tribal in nature so I had a
conversation with Benjamin Netanyahu and
he said fundamentally if you're
anti-zionist you're
anti-semitic so the the the Zionist
project is tied at the hip to the Jewish
project what do you have to say to that
look you can Define
anti-Semitism any way you want right and
you can Define anti-Semitism to
incorporate anti-zionism
uh and and uh I think we have reached
the point where
anti-Semitism is identified today not
just with anti-zionism but with
criticism of Israel if you criticize
Israel people will say some people will
say you're an
anti-semite and if that's your
definition of
anti-semitism it's taken an important
term and stretched it to the point where
it's
meaningless right so when Steve and I
wrote the book um wrote the article and
then wrote the book all sorts of people
said that we were anti-semites this is a
ludicrous charge but what they meant was
you're criticizing the lobby you're
criticizing Israel and therefore you're
an
anti-semite okay if that's what an
anti-semite is somebody who criticizes
Israel you know probably half the Jewish
community if not more in the United
States is anti-Semitic and of course you
get into all these crazy games where
people are calling Jews self-hating Jews
and anti-semites because they're
critical of Israel but even people who
are anti-zionists I don't think they're
anti-semitic at all uh you can argue
they're misguided that's fine but uh
many of these people are Jewish and
proud of the fact that they're Jewish
they just don't believe that nationalism
and Jewish nationalism is a force that
should be applauded and you want to
understand that in the American context
there is a rich tradition of
anti-zionism
right and these were not people who were
anti-semites if you go back to the 30s
40s 50s and the same thing was even true
in Europe there were all sorts of
European Jews who were opposed to
Zionism were they anti-semites I don't
think so but we've gotten to the point
now where people are so interest Ed in
stopping any criticism of Israel that
they wield this weapon of uh calling
people anti-semites uh so uh Loosely
that uh the term has kind of lost
meaning so I I think Netanyahu is is
wrongheaded to equate uh anti-zionism
with anti-Semitism Alan dtz was one of
the people that called you specifically
anti-Semitic
um so
just looking at the space of
discourse how do
you where's a Slither of Hope for
healthy discourse about us relationships
with Israel
uh between you and alen dtz and others
like him well I think until there is a
settlement of the Israeli Palestinian
conflict there's no hope of
putting an end to this nonsense right so
these are just uses of terms to kind
of cheat you way through the through the
discourse it's shortcut no it's the
silence people right it's very very
important to understand that one of the
Lobby's principal goals is to make sure
we don't have an open discourse a
freewheeling discourse about Israel
because they understand people in the
lobby understand that if you have an
open discourse Israel will end up
looking very bad right you don't want to
talk about the occupation you don't want
to talk about how Israel was created
right all all these subjects are ones
that uh will cause problems for Israel
see just to go to the present crisis
okay when you have a
disaster and what happened on October
7th is a disaster one of the first
things that happens is that that people
begin to ask the question how did this
happen right what's the root cause of
this problem this is a disaster we have
to understand what caused it so that we
can work to uh to make sure it doesn't
happen again so we can work to shut it
down and then make sure it doesn't
happen again but once you start talking
about the root causes right you end up
talking about how Israel was created
right and that means telling a story
that is not pretty about how the
zionists conquered
Palestine uh and number two it means
talking about the occupation right it's
not like uh Hamas attacked on October
7th because there were just a bunch of
anti-semites who hated Jews and wanted
to kill Jews this is not you know Nazi
Germany right this is directly related
to the occupation and to what was going
on inside of Gaza and it's not in
Israel's interest or the Lobby's
interest to have an open discourse about
what the Israelis have been doing to the
Palestinians since I would say roughly
1903 when the second alah came to Israel
or came to what was then Palestine right
want to talk about that and we don't
want to talk about from the Lobby's
point of view the influence that the
lobby has right uh uh it's better from
the Lobby's point of view if most
Americans think that uh American support
of Israel is just done for all the right
moral and strategic reasons not because
of the lobby and when John mirer and
Steve Walt come along and say you have
to understand that this special
relationship is due in large part to the
Lobby's influence that is not an
argument that uh people in the lobby
want to hear so the point is you have to
go to Great Lengths for all these
reasons you have to go to Great Lengths
to silence people like me and Steve Walt
and one of the ways to do that is to
call us anti-semites I think the chapter
or the section of the book where we talk
about this charge of anti-Semitism is
called the Great silencer that's what we
call the charge of anti-Semitism the
great silencer who wants to be called an
anti-semite especially in the wake of
the Holocaust do I want to be called an
anti-semite oh my God no
uh and uh so it's very effective but you
know it is important to talk about these
issues in my humble opinion and I think
if we had talked about these issues uh
way back
when it would have gone a long way
towards uh you know maybe getting a
two-state solution which I think was the
best alternative here it it's
complicated and I wonder if you can
comment on the complexity of this
because criticizing Israel and you know
criticizing the
lobby can
um for a lot of people be a dog whistle
for sort of anti-Semitic conspiracy
theories that you know this idea that
Jews run everything run the world or
this kind of
cabal and you know
it's it's also very true that people who
are legitimately
anti-semitic are also critics of Israel
in the same kind of way and so it's such
a complicated landscape in which to have
discussions because
um uh you know even people like David
Duke uh who are you know racists don't
sound racist on the
surface I haven't listened to him enough
but like you know there's dog whistles
it's it's a complicated space in which
to have
discussions because it um I mean I
wonder if you can sort of speak to
that um because there's this silencing
effect of calling everybody anti-semitic
but it's also true that there is
anti-Semitism in the world like there is
a size of population of people that hate
Jews there's probably a sizeable
population of people who hate Muslims
too but you know I a lot of hate out
there a lot of ha out there uh but the
hatred of Jews has like a long history
and so you have like you know Rolling
Stones have a a set of great hits and
there's just a set of great hits of the
ways conspiracy theories that you can
make up about the Jews that are used as
part of the hatred uh so there's like
nice templates for that and I I just
wonder if you can comment
on operating as a historian as an
analyst as a strategic thinker in this
kind of space
yeah we obviously when we wrote the
article which we did before the book
gave the subject a great deal of thought
I mean uh what you say just now is music
to our ears I'm talking for me and about
me and Steve uh I mean I think that you
know your point about dog whistles is
correct look we went to Great Lengths to
make it clear that this is not a cabal
it's not a conspiracy and in fact in a
very important way the lobby operates
out in the open right
uh they brag about their power right and
this was true before we wrote the
article right and um and we said in the
article and the book and you heard me
say it here first of all it's not a
Jewish Lobby right uh um secondly it's
not a cabal right it's an American
interest group and and the American
system is designed such that interest
groups are perfectly legal and some of
them are super effective exact I mean
you hit the nail right on the head
that's exactly right
and you know and there was nothing that
we said that was
anti-semitic by any reasonable
definition of that term and you know
huge numbers of Jews have known me and
Steve over the years and nobody ever
ever said that we were anti-semitic
before March 2006 when the article
appeared because we're not
anti-semitic but look you've got this
interest group right that has a
significant influence on American
policy and un Israeli
policy
and you want to talk about it it's just
important to talk about it it's
important for Jews right in the United
States for Jews in Israel to talk about
this the idea that you want to silence
critics is not a smart way to go about
doing business in my
opinion if we were wrong if Steve and I
were so wrong and our arguments were so
foul they could have easily exposed
those arguments they could have gone uh
into combat with this in terms of the
marketplace of ideas and easily knocked
this down the problem was that our
arguments were quite powerful and
instead of engaging us and defeating our
arguments they wanted to silence us and
this is not good right it's not good for
Israel it's not good for the United
States and I would argue in the end if
anything it's going to Foster
anti-Semitism I think you don't want to
run around telling people that they
can't talk about Israel without being
called an anti-semite it's just not it's
not healthy uh in terms of the issue
that you're raising right but I still
agree with you that it is a tricky issue
it's I I don't want to make light of
that you know I know that there's this
piece of literature out there called the
protocols of the Elders of Zion and I
fully understand that if you're not
careful you can come close to writing
volume two of the protocol but I don't
believe that we wrote anything that was
even close to that and again I think
that a healthy debate on the issues that
we were raising would have been in not
only in America's interest but it would
have been in Israel's
interest yeah I mean um Underneath It
All is just I wonder why there is so
much hate against groups why it's such a
sticky way of
thinking not just tribalism like proud
of your country and kind of hating
another country but really deeply hating
like hating in a way where it's part of
your identity kind of
hate well just to make a general point
on this issue in our conversation here
today you often talk about individual
leaders and the word individual often
pops up in your vocabulary yes I believe
that we are ultimately social animals
before we are individuals I believe
we're born into tribes we're heavily
socialized and that we carve out space
for our
individualism but we are part of tribes
and or social groups or nations call
them what you want ethnic groups
religious groups but the fact is that
these tribes often crash into each other
and when they crash into each other uh
they end up hating each other uh if you
go to a place like Bosnia right the
croats and the serbs oh my God and then
throw in the
bosniacs which is the term for Bosnian
Muslims and you know Muslims croats
serbs uh oh and uh the tribes you know
hate each other uh and uh in a funny way
that hatred almost never goes away uh
and uh I guess there are some exceptions
to that uh if you look at the Germans
after World War II they've gone a long
way towards reducing I wouldn't want to
say completely eliminating but reducing
a lot of the hatred uh that existed
between Germans and their
neighbors uh but that's really kind of
an anomalous case uh I mean you go
around East Asia today and the hatred of
Japan in a place like China the hatred
of Japan in a place like Korea just not
to be
underestimated and uh so but I think a
lot of it just has to do with the fact
that you're dealing with social groups
that have crashed into each other uh at
one point or another and there are those
lingering effects and by the way this
gets back to our discussion a few
minutes ago about trying to get a
two-state solution between the
Palestinians and the Israeli Jews now
that you have had
uh this horrible War which is
ongoing it's
interesting to ask to go back to World
War II now you said uh you studied Nazi
Germany in in the 30s from a perspective
of
maybe offensive
realism uh but just to look at the
Holocaust it's sometimes popular in
public discourse today to compare
certain things to the Holocaust people
have compare the Hamas attack on Israel
to the
Holocaust saying things like it's the
the
biggest attack on Jews since the
Holocaust which kind
of
implies that there's a
comparison people have made that same
comparison in the other
direction what do you make of this
comparison is it comparable is it is the
use of the
Holocaust
uh have any accuracy in comparisons of
modern day international
politics is it possible that you could
have another
genocide yes and I would argue that what
you had in Randa was a
genocide right the Holocaust is not the
only
genocide I believe the word genocide is
used too Loosely
today uh and as you know lots of people
and I mean lots of people who are pro
Palestinian accuse the Israelis of
engaging in genocide in Gaza I think
what the Israelis are doing in Gaza uh
represents a massacre I would use that
term given the number of civilians that
they've killed and the fact that they've
been indiscriminate in terms of how
they've been bombing Gaza but I would
not use the word genocide
uh for me a genocide is where one side
attempts to eliminate another group from
the planet uh I think that what happened
with the Holocaust was clearly a
genocide and that the Germans were bent
uh on destroying all of European jewry
and if they could have gotten their
hands on uh Jews outside of Europe they
would have murdered them as well that's
a genocide and I think with the hus and
the tootsies you had a similar situation
uh I think with the Turks and the
Armenians during World War I that was a
genocide but I have a rather narrow
definition of what a genocide is and I
don't think there are many cases that
qualify as a genocide the Holocaust
certainly does okay
now what Hamas did doesn't even come
close to what happened to European jury
between
let's say
1939 uh and 1945 although I date the
start of the Holocaust to
1941 if we were you know looking at it
closely but let's just say 1939 when
they invade Poland from 1939 to
1945 what mosted pales in comparison
it's hard to believe anybody would make
that argument right yes a lot of Jews
died uh but uh uh hardly
uh uh hardly any compared to the number
that died uh you know at the hands of
the Germans I mean had just no parallel
at all uh and furthermore Hamas was in
no position to kill all the Jews in the
Middle East just not not going to happen
yeah but there's also levels of things
you know using uh Germans using uh human
skin for lamps there's just levels of
evil in this world yes but you don't see
that with I mean that's not what Hamas
is doing I mean I I I want to be very
clear here I am not justifying the kill
hamas's killing of civilians okay not
for one second but I'm just saying and
and and by the way just to go to the
Israelis and what they're doing in Gaza
right as I said to you before I do
believe that is a massacre and I believe
that's to be condemned the killing of
civilians uh this is not legitimate
collateral damage they're directly
punishing the population but I would not
call that a genocide right and I would
not compare that to the Holocaust for
for one second I just want to be very
clear on that do you think
uh if Israel could they would avoid the
death of any
civilians so you're saying there's some
degree of punishment of collective
they're purposely killing civilians it's
this is the Iron Wall they're trying to
beat the pal Palestinians in a
submission
right there's no way you kill this many
civilians
um if you're trying to precisely take
out Hamas Fighters and by the way the
Israeli spokesman the IDF spokesman has
explicitly said that we are not pursuing
Precision bombing and that what we are
doing is trying to you know maximize the
amount of Destruction and damage
uh that we can inflict on the
Palestinians and uh I I I think this is
a major mistake on the part of Israel
first of all it ends up being a moral
stain on your reputation number one and
number two it doesn't work it doesn't
work the the Palestinians are not going
to roll over and submit to uh Israeli
domination of their
life um so you know the the whole
concept of the Iron Wall uh gabatin
Sky's term was
misguided um and and and by the way the
iron if you look at what the Israelis
are doing they're trying to do two
things one is the iron wall and that's
where you punish the civilian population
in Gaza and get them to submit the other
thing that they're trying to do is get
Hamas they want to destroy Hamas and the
belief there is that if they destroy
Hamas they've solved the problem but as
many Israelis know including people on
the hard right even if you destroy Hamas
they are going to be replaced by another
group another resistance group uh and
that resistance group will employ Terror
yeah I think you I think you've said
that uh other terrorist organizations
have used the situation in Palestine as
a as a kind of a recruit recruitment
mechanism for for a long time Osama bin
lad made it clear that this was one of
his principle reasons for attacking the
United States right and the United
States attacked back and uh got us into
a 20-year war that
cost the lives of millions of people not
not American but uh human
beings and uh engaged in torture in
torture yeah no I think if you look at
how we reacted to 911
and how the Israelis are reacting to
what happened on October 7th uh there's
uh quite a bit of similarity in that
both sides the Israeli side and the
American side uh are enraged right and
they lash out and they go on a
rampage and the end result is not good
is there a capacity within Israel or
with within United States after 9/11 to
do do something approximating turn the
other
cheek
of understanding the root of Terror is
hate and fighting that hate
with uh not the naive but
compassion well I I don't think in
either case you're going to turn the
other cheek uh I think well some I what
I mean by that is some limited powerful
military response but very limited yeah
coupled with a smart political strategy
political strategy diplomacy yeah that's
what they should have done yeah right
but is there capacity for that or from
your offensive realism perspective it's
just the odds are really
low no from my offensive realist
perspective or my realist perspective
that's what you should do right my my
view is states are rational actors they
should be cunning right they should
think about
uh the Strategic situation they're in
and choose the appropriate response and
uh what happens and this is why my
theory is not always correct is that
sometimes states are not rational and
they
misbehave I would argue in the Israeli
case uh that it would have been good
after October 7th or starting on October
7th if the United States had uh tried to
hold the Israelis back and
countenance uh a more uh moderate
response a more uh to to SP take some
time just to think about how to deal
with this problem instead of lashing out
I I think given what happened to the
Israelis given how shocked they were
given the level of fear given the level
of Rage they were going to lash out and
I don't believe that was in their
interest I think would have been made
would have made sense to to think about
it and uh to think about a smarter
strategy than they're now employing and
I think you know the Americans blew it
the Americans gave them a be hug and a
green light and said we'll give you all
the Weaponry you need and go out and do
it and uh I don't think that was the
smart thing to do look in the wake of
October 7th the Israelis had no good
strategy right it's it's not like
there's a magic formula that they just
didn't see and we should have told them
what the magic formula was right that's
not true they were in a sense quau
between Iraq and a hard place in terms
of what to do but they're smarter things
and Dumber things and I think the
israelies lashed out in ways that are
counterproductive I think you know going
on a rampage and you know killing huge
numbers of civilians is not it's
obviously morally wrong but it's also
just not in their strategic interest
right I mean uh because it's it's not
going to buy them anything right and in
fact it's going to cost them right
because people all over the planet are
turning against Israel uh I saw you know
an Israeli think tank today uh that has
been tracking uh protests around the
world
um gave some figures for what it looked
like uh between October 7th and October
13th and terms of the number of uh
protests around the world that were
pro-israel versus Pro Palestine and then
it looked at the numbers from U October
13th up to the present and I think the
numbers were
69% were Pro Palestinian in the first
six days after October 7th
69% and I think 31% take these numbers
with a grain of salt 31% were pro-israel
so I think it was 69 and
31 um and uh since then since October
13th if you look at the number of
protests around the world 95% have been
Pro Palestinian and 5% have been
pro-israel uh and what this tells you is
that public opinion around the world has
shift gifted against Israel and if you
look at some of the demonstrations in
places like London and Washington DC
it's truly amazing the number of people
who are coming out in support of the
Palestinians and uh all of this again is
just to support my point that it was
just not smart for Israel to uh launch
this bombing campaign right you can make
an argument for going after Hamas and
doing it in a surgical way or a surgical
way as possible uh but uh that's not
what they did and again my point to you
is I think that this punishment campaign
is not going to work strategically in
other words they're not going to beat
the Palestinians into submission they're
not going to finish off amas and at the
same time by pursuing this strategy
they're doing huge damage to their
reputation around the world well I just
uh yeah in the wake of October
7th
given the geopolitical
context I think there's a lot of
Leverage to be the great ethical
superpower that demonstrate power
without killing any
civilians and use that leverage
diplomatic leverage to push forward
something like abrahamic Accords with
more nations with with Sai Arabia push
for peace aggressively peace agreements
this kind of stuff economic
relationships all this kind of stuff and
thereby pressure the Palestinian
Authority you know towards
uh perhaps a two-state
solution but I think what you're missing
here just in the Israeli case is that
the Israeli government is not interested
in the two-state solution and you want
to remember that Benjamin Netanyahu who
looks very hawkish when you look at him
in
isolation doesn't look so haw fish when
you look at him compared to the rest of
the people in his cabinet right he he he
almost looks like a moderate he's got a
lot of people who are way out to the
right of him
and these people and this of course
includes Netanyahu are not interested in
the two-state solution so the question
you have to ask yourself is you if
you're if you're Benjamin Netanyahu and
it's July 7th late in the excuse me
October 7th late in the day what do you
do you're not thinking about a two-state
solution you're thinking about an
occupation that's not going to end and
the question is how do you deal with the
Palestinians given what's just happened
well there's people in the cabinet and
then there's history and history
remembers great leaders and so uh
Benjamin and yaho can look in the
streets of Israel and see the protests
and think of how history will remember
him and I think a two-state solution is
on the table table for a great leader
well it was there was he the person who
was going to take advantage of it I
don't I think so but well he's a student
of History well at this point well the
we'll see does I mean it's very at this
point it's very difficult um like you
said 95% now or whatever the number is
of protests I
think the the window in which
Israel has the ears of the world it can
do the the big ethical peace act action
towards peace is uh I think has closed
or maybe there's still a Slither but
it's just
um uh the slippery slope of of hate is
has taken off it's quite depressing to
watch what's going I I agree 100%
unequivocally
depressing